hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video meine damen und herren ja ihr seht
es schon ich sitz hier nicht alleine
sondern apple
ihr seht schon hier vorne links
eingeblendet airbus s kids und auf der
rechten seite befindet sich die lubu
meine damen und herren
ja wer bitburger will bei einigen tagen
haben sie was denn ich hab schon auf
unseren kanälen jeweils ein video
hochgeladen in dem wir uns in fifa
ultimate team ein team zusammengestellt
haben krass dass hier rechts ist jetzt
mein team
das habe ich ja schon vorgestellt und
auch sebastians kanal hat er sein team
hier links vorgestellt und heute meine
damen und herren ist der tag gekommen an
dem das
wir werden jetzt auf jeden fall mit
unseren teams gegeneinander spielen und
der erste der zwei linz hat gewinnt
diese fifa challenge wo manchmal den
neun tore und das ist nämlich auch das
ding freunde es gibt einen neuen trick
wie verachtet was machst du da
eigentlich
ich würde sagen ich bin jetzt einfach
mal auf start
es gibt bei 18 9 trägt der heißt eltern
ado den können aber nur vier spieler und
zwar roberto carlos die rallye anfang
grießmann und cristiano ronaldo leider
haben wir keinen von diesen spielern im
team ich hätte so gerne gemacht ist denn
davon ist das sind die legenden spiele
und theorie aber auch sind jetzt
wirklich für 18 gibt's jetzt icons und
das sind quasi dirigenten spieler hat
zwei davon zwei legenden ich habe zwei
legenden und ich bin orden legende
[Applaus]
okay let's go welche wir haben so lange
uns gegenseitig so gesagt warum ich mich
rasiere ich rasiere dich jetzt ständig
dass wir dich jetzt kommen nur
[Musik]
ich bin so unruhig alter gefragt ob man
sieht schon direkt freude ist ein spiel
auf ein tor ist ein spiel auf ein tor
was das denn was mache ich denn da hatte
ich war nie so nervös ich denke ich bin
so nervös gestand ich kann das gar nicht
kommentieren
der ist gut das nicht verstehen das ist
einfach so wir haben uns sehr dass
nichts müller
[Musik]
junge oper geht in der stockumer ist
schon ein bisschen anspannung aus ja bei
dir ist dir aus
[Applaus]
dort wo mein gott das ist ja alles nur
ein extragewinn ok ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen dass zusammen habe ich jetzt
natürlich nicht gerechnet
junge was tue ich denn du hast auf aber
echt krank gesprungen zu sagen die hat
nur fürst sein 0 warum bist du aufgeregt
ich habe diesen adrenalinschub an der
ericsson hat guten schuss der zwar nicht
zu den besten wert aber ich bin da
schießt richtig gut
wiederum musste außenverteidiger man
muss schon sagen das ist ein sehr
taktisches spiel ich bin eigentlich eher
defensiv eingestellt liege trotzdem zwar
zu null
vor allem gegen neuer alter das ist echt
traurig dass du einfach neues thema wenn
ich jetzt irgendwie 20 hinten liege oder
so ich meine du hast zweiten halbzeit
gemacht kritisiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das geht in die mitte ist kenia wir
könnten ein
man kann nicht reden das ist so krass ja
aber wir kommen schon wow ja er ist so
inspiriert drumherum
warum spielt denn ihnen nicht besser
bahnen nicht muss einfach die chance war
ein bisschen effektiver nutzen egal ich
habe nicht die nerven und macht doch
jetzt noch diskutierten jetzt schön
quick study das bist du also das so
schnell wechseln in filmen wie man das
machen kann er jetzt aber hat es gut
weil sonst musste man immer menü
teammanagement kann man natürlich immer
noch machen aber im spiel geht's einfach
viel schneller show ist die räder für
bagayoko rein und jetzt direkt beim
anstoß da sehen wir noch mal
eingeblendet der abag ag
wetten
da kommen wir wieder bis zum spielende
warten jetzt geben
nein warum kennen diese chance
nein das ist doch nicht wahr was aber
gar keinen text mehr aufgefallen ich
dachte mir gesagt jetzt als ich selbst
bei vielfalt macht richtig viel
drumherum trickse aber jetzt gerade ist
einfach überhaupt nicht der fall
690 euro
[Musik]
ich hab noch einen verteidiger hast du
gesehen haben verteidiger da gemacht hat
das ist einfach nicht mehr meine tores
und perfekt rausgespielt schön spiel
breit machen guck dir das an das war
mein verteidiger darf versucht mir oder
zu bekommen aber dafür ist beim jahren
geschehe häufig 96 ps power point er
rühmt sich jetzt hier mit pace dings
koma da ist wieder die pace maschine am
start
warum spiele ich den dann noch mal mehr
wohl aber warum kriegst du den dort baum
kriege ich den nicht mein gott jetzt
auch noch nicht noch nicht was soll das
alte schwer ist es einfach glück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da kommen die schüsse nicht präzise oder
ja okay das war der unparteiische sich
nicht einhalten
ja meine damen und herren das war's
jetzt auf jeden fall hier vor dem ersten
spiel gegen er brüskierte die ich möchte
auf jeden fall eine revanche wäre mir
auch gesagt zwei siege braucht man damit
man diese challenge gewinnen das heißt
morgen auf 6 kanal werden wir eine
revanche hochladen meine damen und
herren
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lass gerne like da ich gehe jetzt noch
ein bisschen wein und wir sehen uns
morgen auf sein witz kanal wieder